welcome to our fourth and final
schulman lecture for the semester i'm
not saying that we saved the best for
last
but i'm not denying it either
um our speaker today is professor
elizabeth spelke she is the marshall
berkman professor of psychology at
harvard where she also co-directs the
laboratory for developmental studies
she is certainly one of the world's most
prominent
um
and impressive cognitive scientists and
in my only hesitation in saying that is
that i'm not sure the word cognitive is
necessary liz is also just one of the
world's most prominent and impressive
scientists
this is true in terms of both concrete
methods and abstract deep theory
methodologically liz has pioneered
new ways of reading the minds of babies
with elegant behavioral measures
theoretically she's used these methods
to transform our understanding of our
own minds and where they come from
and she has done this not just in one or
two case studies but for essentially
every primary aspect of our minds
that we care about characterizing what
she calls our core knowledge of objects
space number physics geometry social
agents and beyond
and i think those categories are very
important but also sort of a little dry
and abstract
in the context of doing this
liz has also studied everything from
food and shadows and maps
to race and accents and kinship
to music and singing to a paper in
science earlier this year that looked at
infants appreciation of intimacy and
saliva sharing
that's the first time we have uttered
that phrase in the shulman seminar
in almost any aspect of these areas and
beyond you can find her work both at the
foundations and the cutting edge
as one person has called her she is the
quote preeminent researcher of the basic
ingredient list from which all human
knowledge
is constructed
and if this is starting to sound a bit
too grandiose i will just note that a
profile of her once noted that she had
summarized on her lab's bulletin board
her current research program
in terms of quote blocks and holes
talking blobs and wet animals
and i will confess liz i've never known
i i get the other two i've never known
quite what to make of the wet animals
thing but now that i see the saliva
sharing maybe i'm starting to uh to see
that
liz has done all of this while being one
of the most positive and nurturing
people in our field the list of students
she's worked with is really a who's who
of cognitive science at this point and
she is a role model for so many of us
um in fact if you'll permit one slightly
disturbing story um
i've only ever had one negative thought
about liz in my career it was early on
and it was my mistake um when i was a
second year graduate student i think in
1995 or some prehistorical time like
that
i uh i wrote one of the first papers i
had ever written and for some reason it
occurred to me as as it happens to one
that like liz spelke needs to read this
paper and so i emailed her out of the
blue as a graduate student and i said
hey i've done this work on blah blah
blah and would you be willing to take a
look at it and she responded in about
like 10 seconds
by email and said it was such a warm and
and nice message saying i would love to
to check that out please send it to me
it sounds so interesting um i'm in
france this summer please send it along
i'll get you back comments right away
and i was so excited
and she never wrote back to me
um
and so i thought that was sort of the
the genesis of this negative thought
that for years i thought like wow she
seemed so warm but it was like a con she
never got back to me and then i finally
met her years later um and she seemed so
nice and i was hesitant to bring it up
and then two years after that this is
like six years after i had sent this
paper i got the paper back and this is
the slightly disturbing story that paper
had been in the mail on flight twa 800
which for those of you who don't
remember this this is a flight that
famously was on its way to france and
crashed over long island sound they
recovered the paper from the bottom of
long island sound and it had been in the
custody of the agencies investigating
the crash for years i don't think they
found any causal connection
uh between the work though so uh liz i
apologize for thinking that negative
thought about you for all those years it
wasn't your fault
um i'll end just by noting that liz has
won
basically just all of the honors that
our field has to bestow among many
others she's a member of the aaas and
the national academy of sciences
she is a corresponding fellow of the
british academy for the humanities and
social sciences
she and her work have been profiled in
both the new yorker and the new york
times
she's won the jean-nico prize the kirk
kafka medal the heineken prize for
cognitive sciences the william james
award from the american psychological
society the distinguished scientific
contribution award from the american
psychological association i think most
important she won a distinguished alumni
award from the new canaan country school
here in connecticut
but
she has not yet delivered a shulman
lecture here at yale please welcome
elizabeth
[Applause]
i don't know whether to thank you or not
for that introduction
on the one hand i'm not going to talk
about any of those lines of work uh if
you want to know about saliva sharing
you're going to have to ask me over
drinks or something afterwards okay
second while i might have been innocent
on that particular occasion anybody who
knows me knows that i'm way more
enthusiastic about what i say i'm going
to read than i actually end up having
time to read so while i might have been
innocent in that particular case
you shouldn't conclude across the board
that that's
going to be true
one thing i do have to say is i'm again
coming from paris and i am so happy uh
to be here with all of you this is my
first real talk in person talk since the
pandemic started it's been totally fun
i've had a really great day so far and
i'm very happy to be here with you i'm
also under strict orders that i can't go
over 45
minutes which is one of the reasons why
i'm not going to talk about any of the
topics that were on brian's list and
also um a reason why i've decided to do
something that i've actually never done
at a talk before which is to start with
the final conclusion so that if my
optimistic assessment that i'm going to
be done in 45 minutes turns out to be
wrong you won't be missing the message
of this
talk so
so there are three general
conclusions to this talk
the first is that between our perceptual
systems and the systems in which we uh
use our explicit concepts and form
beliefs and communicate our beliefs to
others there's an important level of
representation
it's a level of representation that i
think is often not recognized uh
in uh either philosophy or the sciences
i think certainly when i was a student i
was taught that there were two kinds of
systems uh in the mind there were the
automatic systems that control our
perceptions and our actions and uh there
were there were the
conscious deliberate uh accessible
systems in which we formulated and
expressed our beliefs and that that the
mind divided into these two parts uh
today they're sometimes called things
like thinking fast versus thinking slow
um peripheral processes versus central
processes that this is how the mind
divides up but i actually think there's
an important level of representation
between those two levels i don't deny
the existence of either of those two
levels but i think if we really want to
understand how our minds work and answer
some basic questions about how are we
all the same and how are we different uh
how did chil and how do children learn
that it really helps uh to focus on a
level that that mediates between and
remains constant over all of the changes
in what we perceive and uh what we
believe
now the second general lesson is that at
this level
concepts that are highly general and
that capture properties of the world
that are highly abstract
actually emerge in development before
concepts that are more
specific
and i think this is true both when we
look over human ontogeny and also when
we look over
the evolution of life on earth
if that's true it implies that the ways
in which infants and other animals are
like us
are not that they share our basic
reflexes or sensory experiences but that
they share our basic the
their sensitivity our sensitivity to the
basic abstract properties of causality
and space and time that structure our
world those are the ways in which other
animals are most uh like us um and i
think this also goes against widespread
intuitions about what we have in common
with our house cats and or what we as
adults have in common uh with newborn
infants that we might share some of
their emotions we might share some of
their sensory uh experiences some of
their reflex actions but surely not uh
the basic abstract distinctions by which
we understand the world that i think is
is how we intuitively tend to think
about infants and animals uh but i think
this research suggests that that's not
right uh and that it's really the
abstract concepts that are most likely
to be common uh to us at all ages and
also common to different species and
hence the first part of my title um the
primordial blessing of abstraction which
i'll try to unpack over the course of um
this talk
and then the third
lesson
goes against sort of the most
fundamental thing that people were
always saying to me uh when i was a
student and then again when i started
doing research in this field and would
find evidence that some abilities seem
to be innate
the idea was that something is either
innate or it is learned
and if it's innate then it's not learned
and if it's if it's learned then it's
not innate uh and that's all of course
true
but what people seem to often think
followed from that was that the more
innate knowledge you have the less you
have to learn because all the stuff that
you know that's a need is not learned
uh i actually think that the reverse is
true
that the more innate concept well let me
put it this way
if we lived in a perfect unchanging
world
uh where throughout the evolution of
life on earth the environment stayed
exactly the same and predictable in
exactly the same ways then maybe it
would be true that the more innate
concepts you had uh the less you needed
to learn but in the actual world that
all animals live in the world is
changing and it's uncertain and in that
circumstance
the more innate concepts you have the
more of a learning problem you face
because you have to discover which
concepts to call on in any given
situation which ones are going to be
useful and what they're going to be
useful for and this is what i call the
curse of a
compositional mind so what i want to do
today is my talk is in two parts the
first part is going to be an attempt to
convey to you in 30 minutes what is soon
to appear in a humongously long book
which covers exactly one year in human
life it starts at birth and it goes to
one year of age
and tries to talk about what i think
the cognitive sciences have learned
about
what infants know
over the course of that first year
especially in the early part of that
first year so i'm going to spend two
thirds of my talk focused on that
and then i want to turn to the problem
that i'm working on now and which i hope
will someday become volume 2 of
the next book and the next and last
book in this series
i want to turn to the question of how
children learn and in particular uh
focus on what i think is a
learning process that's unique to our
species and that helps account for how
we can be so similar to other animals at
birth in our abstract
the abstract concepts that we apply to
the world and yet find ourselves on such
a different path of development when we
start to grow
explicit knowledge so to start with what
infants know let me see if i can get all
this on one slide they know that there
are objects that the world that they
have entered is going to have bodies in
it that are solid then that move
continuously through space and that
interact with one another uh on contact
um
and i think they may also uh this
knowledge may be accompanied by
capacities uh to form mental simulations
of these objects and their uh
interactions
they know that there are places and that
places are arrayed on a surface over
which you can navigate uh that that
surface depending on how it's contoured
will afford navigation on some paths and
not others
and
with that surface as you travel over it
you can learn how uh what different
paths connect different places in the
space uh to one another
most tentatively i think that they know
that there are living beings in the
world with characteristic forms and
characteristic functions for us and for
themselves
that live anchored to this surface
and their forms and functions both may
be captured initially
by something like shape skeletons
and now coming away from the tentative
more to things where there's more
evidence
i think that they know there are agents
that cause their own motion and by
moving cause changes in the world and
that they uh move by pursuing goals
efficiently
to bring them
valued and accessible objects
i think they know there are social
beings who share their experience who
experience the world as we do and who
share their experiences with one another
or with us in states of engagement
and i think they know that
they have a system for representing when
any of the eight entities i just
described congregate in groups or are
arrayed in sequences of events they have
a system for representing their
approximate numerosity
a system that they can use for diverse
purposes but maybe especially for
learning probabilistic learning about
the properties of the world and also
making decisions and planning actions
so
these different things that infants know
i think
stem from six different
cognitive systems that i call systems of
core knowledge that have a number of
interesting properties uh in common
uh the most important is that they
center on abstract concepts that are
interconnected to one another and here
i've just put pointers to the uh
distinctive concepts that i think
arise from each of these different core
systems
but for the rest of the properties i
want to take the place system to
quickly kind of unpack them for you
the second property of these core
systems is that they're limited
so when
uh infants or inexperienced animals
begin to navigate through space
they're navigating through a very rich
environment where they have multiple
systems that they can use to pick out
landmark objects to pick out all
different kinds of surfaces to see
colors to see uh shapes uh and so forth
but when they
face the task of determining where they
are and what paths they should take to
get from where they are to somewhere
else in the environment they disregard
almost all of this information and rely
on only one thing which is the ground
surface over which they move and its
perturbations that's an example of a
limit on a core system a limit on the
the things that it serves to represent
uh in addition to being limited the uh
the representations from the core
systems are shared when we look at the
abstract properties that characterize
them and the limits for each system we
get evidence that they're shared by
other animals that is it's not only the
case that we see objects and that other
animals see objects but we see objects
under the same conditions and with the
same by using the same abstract
properties that other animals do and
with the same limits on what we
represent that we find in
other animals now that gives us reason
to believe that these systems are
ancient that they evolved long before
we emerged as a species and ancestors
that are common to us and to other
animals
now because uh they're ancient they can
be studied in animals not only at a
behavioral level but at a neural level
and this is of course has been done
famously and richly in the case of the
place system uh providing evidence that
navigation relies on specialized neural
mechanisms in the hippocampus and and
surrounding cortex
that these mechanisms are present uh in
animals throughout their lives they were
found first in mature animals but then
also tracked down in development and
found in animals at the very beginning
just beginning to navigate through the
environment
armed with this information functional
brain imaging studies revealed the same
mechanisms in humans uh providing yet
more evidence uh that we share common
systems with these other
animals and also providing evidence that
in humans as well as other animals these
systems are present throughout life
they're not scaffolding that you use as
an infant to get cognitive development
going and then throw away as you uh
latch on to other kinds of
concepts and representations rather they
continue to function in us
throughout our lives and in other
species as well now because these
systems continue to function in adults
you can do experiments like some of the
gorgeous experiments that brian did
generations ago
you can do experiments uh where you
catch them in action in adult minds
uh and when you do this if you then ask
people what are you thinking about while
you're in this experiment you discover
that these systems are operating
automatically and effortlessly and
unconsciously
but you also discover that different
systems representations from different
systems compete with one another for
attention so again to use the place
system as an example
when adults are in a virtual navigation
task so they're navigating on a you know
with a joystick looking at a computer
screen through some environment uh
they're able to we're able to navigate
uh to find our our way to an object in
at least two different ways one by using
objects in the environment as landmarks
and marking where we are relative to
them
and two by using the ground surface over
and its perturbations over which uh uh
we're we're moving now what you find in
adults is we can use both of these
systems but on any given occasion as we
use one it will tend to suppress the
activity and the neural mechanisms that
support the other system so you see a
competition between them and oh and by
the way if you then ask adults what were
you doing on that trial and was it any
different from what you did on other
trials they uh
generally cannot tell you it's not that
we're consciously making decisions that
we're going to rely on one system or the
other it's that they're automatically
activated but in a competitive um
resource limited manner
finally the systems support children's
learning in the case of the spa the the
the navigation system learning the
layout of uh their local environment
where things are and how you get from
one place to another and there's some uh
evidence in the case of the police
system that this learning depend uh and
also decision making about which path to
take through the layout uh are heavily
influenced by a capacity that's been
found both in adult animals and also um
uh in young animals to s for mental
simulations of travel through the
environment
so when an animal confronts a choice
point a new choice point that it hasn't
confronted before of taking either of
two different paths to get to a goal
object it may well stop at that choice
point and simulate one path or the other
path and you can track these simulations
if you're monitoring what activity is
going on uh in their in their
hippocampus and then the ultimate
decision that the animal makes uh
will the effectiveness of that decision
can be linked to the effectiveness of
the simulations that it had engaged in
and that same process has also been
found in young animals and also in human
uh adults so in the case of place
representations there is evidence that
processes of mental stimulation
enter into our learning about the uh
layout of the environment the reason i
qualified this conclusion here is that
to my knowledge there is no evidence for
any
mental direct evidence for mental
simulations in human infants
so that remains a
an untested
hypothesis but the last general thing i
want to say before plunging into some
more details
is that these different properties of
core knowledge systems are not just a
random laundry list of properties that
have collected over time i think they're
interestingly related to each other
and that any system that has some of
these properties is highly likely to
have all of them
and to see this let's start with the um
property of um the ancient origins of
these systems and think back to
creatures who lived hundreds of millions
of years ago
common ancestors to us and some of the
fish or maybe even fruit flies in some
cases uh and other animals who navigate
through the world in some of the same
ways that we do and imagine that this
ancestor lived in the water
uh and fed on a certain kind of food and
the environment in which it lived lasted
long enough that it was able to evolve
multiple mechanisms for guiding itself
to the sources of food first of all the
sources
occurred in predictable locations so
they could by representing their own
position and the distances and
directions of those locations from uh
their home position they were able to
use the geometry of the layout to get uh
to navigate to food
but the food also probably had a
characteristic odor uh chemical
composition which might have created
gradients uh in the water that they were
swimming through and they may well have
evolved other mechanisms for
detecting the food visually or detecting
the chemical gradients but now think
about their descendants over subsequent
evolution the environments changed and
the animals changed some of them grew
bigger they grew smaller their energy
requirements were no longer met by that
kind of food they had other kinds of
food
so any mechanisms that were specific to
the smell or the chem the the site or
the chemical composition of that food
would be no longer relevant to the
descendants from that ancestors on the
way to uh to getting to us
but for all of those intermediate
species uh the the euclidean structure
of the environment would have been the
same the mechanism for navigating by the
distances and directions of food sources
from the animal would be useful no
matter what environment that animal was
in so any system that was
ancient is very likely to focus on
properties of the world that are
abstract that apply in all environments
and that are limited that don't apply to
things like what stuff looks like what
it smells like the superficial
properties of things that differ uh from
one environment to another
but if um a system captures abstract uh
properties those properties are going to
be extremely useful if they apply in all
environments and they're going to imply
not only in all environments but to
people of all ages
even as people change their environment
uh if their lifestyle brings about you
know they they migrate or something they
travel to new environments uh these
basic abstract properties of the world
will apply in all of those environments
from which it follows that these uh
systems if they emerge in infants are
very likely to stay present and
functional uh throughout
the um
throughout our lives and support our
subsequent learning and our subsequent
reasoning no matter what problems we
find ourselves um
confronted with
what's more
the systems are likely to be neurally
specialized and
to operate automatically and
unconsciously because if you have a
system that works in every environment
that you're ever going to be in then you
don't need to waste your conscious
decision-making resources on figuring
out should i be using it or not yes you
should always be using it you should be
using it automatically however there is
a problem uh which is that i guess i
didn't put this property on the list but
there there is a problem that we have
multiple such systems but we can only do
one thing at a time so i think it makes
sense that these systems although
they're automatic and operate
unconsciously nevertheless compete for
resources so that animals aren't pulled
in multiple different directions
at any given moment in time
and then finally i think these systems
may serve
to simulate the entities that
populate the world
that that we
find
in these systems
because they're supporting our learning
automatically and um effortlessly
they're they're they're able to do this
from the very beginning since they're
focusing on abstract properties that
don't depend on what things are
particularly going to look like in one
environment than in the relative to
another this could be um a useful way to
prepare animals for the world that
they're going to be
encountering so that's all the
conclusions of the talk now i can
actually get to the beginning of the
talk and uh thank you
and um what i want to do is focus on
three of these systems to set up the
second part of the talk where i um ask
how children learn i think a lot of how
children learn depends on the ways in
which as infants they represent objects
and agents and social beings now i was
actually here and some of you uh heard
me talk here before the uh pandemic uh
so i want to go very quickly over stuff
that we already knew back then i'll only
talk very quickly about what infants
know about objects but then tell you
about some new work we've been doing on
infants representations of agents and
social beings but not saliva sharing
brian sorry about that
okay objects
so what do babies know about objects
only really abstract things they don't
know what they're going to look like
they don't know what kind of categories
they're going to fall into but they know
that out there in the world they're
going to be bodies that move as cohesive
holes
that
are fully interconnected so if parts of
them are moving together there's going
to be connections
between those parts even if they aren't
directly visible
and
that move on unique connected pads
through space and over time so if an
object appears behind the left screen
and then an object
comes into view disappears behind the
left screen and then an object comes
into view from behind the right screen
but there was no
object moving between the two infants
can conclude that there were two objects
participating in that event and if a
screen comes up and covers an object um
uh infants can predict that that screen
should it's it's rotating backward
infants can predict that that's green
should stop its rotation when it reaches
the point where that object is located
even though it's no longer uh visible
because two things can't be in the same
place at once and if one object that
that red block moves toward a um
a blue cylinder that's partly that's
initially stationary behind a screen and
then after it disappears the blue
cylinder starts to move infants and fur
that the block will have
contacted the cylinder that they uh
interacted on contact now interestingly
resurgence by susan carey has shown that
if one of these prop it's not that
infants can't tolerate violations of
these properties you can violate them
but if you violate one of these
properties they suspend all their
predictions about the others so the
properties seem to be interconnected
these aren't just separate things that
infants know about objects they're
they're they're uh
connected together and they um rise and
fall together
and all of these abilities they've been
studied in infants at a variety of
different ages they've been rebuilding
in human infants at different ages and
very few of them have been tested in
newborn infants but all of them have
been tested in controlled weird animals
of various species and when when tested
they've been found to be present and
functional on an animal's first
encounter perceptual encounter with um
uh an object
okay but these abilities are extremely
limited and i'm going to mention just
one limit from a classic experiment
conducted 25 years ago or set of
experiments
by fei shu and susan carey
with 10 month old infants these were
studies in which infants were shown
objects that very likely were familiar
to them like a shoe baby's shoe that
went behind a screen
and a rubber ducky that came out from
the other side of the screen
and after seeing that event repeatedly
they were asked in effect how many
objects are behind the screen by taking
the screen away and on alternating
trials revealing either both objects or
only one of them
measuring and measuring how long infants
who hadn't seen the previous events
looked at those two displays and
comparing that to how long the infants
who saw the previous events looked at
them what they found is that uh the
previous events in no way disposed the
infants to conclude that there were two
objects behind the screen they seemed
completely open-minded about whether
there were two objects behind that
screen or one shoe that turned itself
into a duck during the time that it was
hidden now you could think well maybe
this is just a memory problem the kids
weren't keeping track of the appearance
of the objects but you and carrie showed
that that wasn't true
because if you measured how interested
they were in the events where the shoe
and the duck alternately appeared
relative to events where the duck
appeared on both sides of the screen or
the shoe appeared on both sides of the
screen they were more interested when
there was a change in features
also
in tasks involving no memory demands
where the question for the infants is
not what's happening when it's when
these things are out of view but rather
if i lift the duck what's going to
happen to the truck will it come with it
or will it stay on the table are these
one connected body or are they two
separate bodies the infants were neutral
between those two possibilities even as
many of them demonstrated that they
recognized the duck by saying quack
quack while they looked at this display
or the truck and so forth so it looks
like infants can recognize some objects
and even imitate their functions without
using that information to answer the
question where does this object end and
the other one uh begin to track objects
over time so this suggests that when
reasoning about object motion infants
are representing objects as bodies but
not as kinds with characteristic forms
and functions i think a way of thinking
about this is these are telling the this
is a system that's telling infants what
individual things are out there in the
world but not how should these things be
categorized and what generalizations
should i form over those um uh
categories and here i think there's a
parallel with the um physics engines
that josh tenenbaum may have talked
about when he was here uh and which i
know some of you um uh have been
interested in uh working on that
simulate object motions and uh
interactions but let me move on to
some stuff that we're working on
actively now infants early developing
understanding of people as agents
so over the last 25 years or so we've
learned a fair amount about people have
learned a fair amount about infants
expectations about how agents will and
will not act
we've learned that agents tend to act
efficiently to achieve their goals so if
an agent consistently reaches for an
object over a barrier and then the
barrier is removed they'll change the
trajectory of their reach to the more
efficient direct reach
for that object
we also know that infants will take
higher cost actions to attain goals of
greater value so if infants see that the
little red agent is willing to climb a
steep hill to get to the yellow guy but
only a shallow hill to get to the blue
guy then when the two the yellow and
blue guys both appear on a level playing
field they expect the agent to go to the
one that they had taken a more costly
action to get to previously
and finally we know that
babies expect that agents will act on
things that are perceptually accessible
to them
uh and uh
when they do their actions will reveal
their relative value that they give to
each of these objects
so this is work by you yuyon
luo and susan johnson in which on the
two top
lines you see
experiments in which an agent can see
each of two objects and reaches for one
of them and under those conditions
infants infer that the agent prefers
that object to the other object
contrasted with two conditions in which
the agent can only see one of the two
objects either because the other is
fully hidden behind a screen or because
their back is turned to the other object
and in that condition they make no
inference about whether the agent
prefers the object that she reaches for
to the other object only when she can
see it do they think that that there's a
preference now these properties also
connect to each other
inferences about preferences connecting
to inferences about visibility
inferences
connecting also to inferences about the
amount of cost you would take for an
action uh and so forth and they also
connect to a further abstract property
namely that agents actions cause changes
in the world and for this i want to talk
very quickly about a study that i talked
about at much more length when i was
here um uh three years ago
that showed that babies um when when
infants at of about uh three months of
age that is infants who are not yet able
to reach for objects and pick them up or
act on them systematically basically all
a three-month-old baby can do if you
show them an object within near reaching
distances they kind of go like this and
look like they would really like you to
give them the object but they can't
actually get it themselves and if you
move it close enough that they might
bump into it they actually bat it away
okay they can't actually reach
engage in a coordinated reach for an
object so we take infants of that age
and ask
if you show them another person acting
on an object and causing a change in
that object on contact do they see that
as a goal-directed action and in
particular will they infer that it will
be efficient so in this condition shari
liu showed a person uh actually she used
to be here as a postdoc at one point
elia martin um reaching over a barrier
touching an object and the object lights
up and makes a noise and then
the barrier is removed and the infants
see a direct reach and an indirect reach
alternately for the object and the
question is which did they expect to see
and she compared this condition to a
condition that was made with exactly the
same videos differing only in one half
second for this condition the the video
was modified so that the hand stopped
short of the object and froze in that
position and then after a half second
gap in time the object lit up so no
spatio-temporal contiguity between the
action and the um
effect on the object and what she found
was that in the contact condition the
babies expected the efficient reach in
the no contact condition
they
did not expect the efficient reach they
had no expectation so it looks like
before infants can pick up an object
themselves they construe other people's
actions as costly but only if they also
see them as causal okay uh in the
non-causal condition uh that uh that
effect uh didn't occur
now those are uh the interconnected
abstract concepts that we see in in uh
in young infants but there's a limit to
young infants agent knowledge of
their their knowledge about the actions
of agents that was discovered by amanda
woodward and jessica somerville that
we've been curious about um it comes up
in a simple situation that works
beautifully with a five-month-old infant
uh five-month-old infants by the way are
now by then in the business of picking
up objects and manipulating them and
these infants are shown a person who
consistently reaches for one of two
objects presented in constant positions
in this case reaching for the ball which
is always on the left uh and then in uh
woodward asks how are babies
understanding that reach how are they
representing uh that action
uh by allowing babies to see that event
repeatedly and then reversing the
positions of the two objects and
alternately presenting a reach on a
novel path to a novel location but where
the same object is versus a reach on a
the familiar path now to a novel object
and at five months of age babies expect
the reach on the novel path to the
familiar object and look longer at the
other one okay so they see this reach as
directed to the ball in this case not
directed to a particular location in
space that's at five months at three
months they saw something very different
the babies were equal
had no expectation about whether the
where the reach uh would be
directed
then later they saw a different
development that also seemed to track
the the development of the baby's own
action capacities this is a case where
uh studied uh
at length by piaget many generations
earlier where babies have to do one
thing like pull they see somebody who
does one thing pulling on a cane
in order to create the conditions where
they can do a second thing
uh grab pick up an object that was
previously out of reach but that the
cane brought within reach and when they
presented this event to 12 month old
infants the infants recognized that the
goal of the action was the toy that was
out of reach uh by that age they're also
inclined to use canes to pull uh toys
into their reaching space but at eight
months before they engage in that um
uh two-step action they took the goal to
be the cane itself not to be the toy so
again it looked like there was a limit
to
infants understanding of other people's
actions and that the limits are overcome
at the point at which the the infants
themselves master those actions but this
raises the question how do infants
understand actions that they can't yet
perform
and what woodward and somerville
suggested is that they don't understand
them they see the the behavior of the
agents in these studies as purposeless
until they get to the point where they
themselves have and and can realize
these purposes and then they start
endowing other people with them uh but
we thought maybe we could get young
babies to succeed earlier in
understanding that these actions were
goal directed and we now is brandon wu
and shari liu and our first attempt to
do this focused on the same uh woodward
situation that i just described with
three-month-old infants and we just did
one thing different based on the last
study i told you about that sherry had
performed we
had a person reach for one of two
objects the bear or the toy but always
consistently for one of them but at the
point at which the person contacted that
object both objects lit up okay and the
thinking was well we know that action at
a distance doesn't work so touching this
the babies shouldn't think that that
will have a causal effect on this object
but they should think it'll have a
causal effect on that one and maybe that
would lead them to succeed in a woodward
experiment i so we then switch the
locations to see what would happen and i
fully expected that this study would
work and this is the point at which this
is what i'm in this business for okay i
was dead wrong about that the babies
taught me something
they were looked absolutely equally at
the change in object and the change in
location they had no preference for one
over the other so i needed to rethink uh
what was going uh on here and it seemed
like there were two possibilities maybe
more than two but these were the two
that we focused on
one is the uh woodward somerville
possibility babies are just seeing these
movement these uh the the people as
engaged in aimless purposeless goalless
movements okay but it seemed like there
was a second possibility
maybe in the same way that babies use
core knowledge of objects to represent
individual objects but not kinds of
things uh
maybe they use core representations of
agents to represent individual actions
without understanding that there are
kinds of actions there are acts of
navigation that serve to take you from
place to place and there are acts of
manipulating objects that serve to get
you to particular objects that have
particular affordances that you want to
capitalize on maybe they don't have that
second level
in which case they might perfectly well
think of this person as acting in a
goal-directed manner
but be open to the possibility that that
goal could be either an object or a
location in space okay so to distinguish
those possibilities brandon and sherry
ran two more experiments here's one of
them this experiment involved
familiarizing infants with reaches to
one object at two different locations uh
so for some of the infants uh here's
what the familiarization was this person
always reached for the bear uh but on
alternating trials the bear appeared in
the middle of the display or on the left
side of the display across different
babies uh we varied which object was the
goal and whether it was the left on the
left or on the right and so forth but
they repeatedly saw that the guy was
going for the object regardless of which
of two locations it was at and then they
were tested
uh with that object in a completely new
location that had never appeared before
versus the other object which had never
been reached for in one of the two uh
familiar locations so that's the uh
woodward uh
situation but with information that it's
the object and not the location that
matters and in this case now we see the
woodward effect we see the infants
expecting a reach to a new location for
the familiar object to be more similar
to
they they deem that to be more similar
to what they were seeing before and
therefore less newsworthy and so they
look at it uh less long now that could
be for either of two reasons they're
three months old
they've been looking at events in which
other people reach for objects and pick
them up and manipulate them that's how
they get all this nice motion
information about objects most of the
time
so they could be predisposed to
learn that reaches tend to be directed
to objects possibility one or
possibility two they could be completely
open-minded
and be equally ready to learn that
reaches are directed to locations in
space so the last experiment tested for
that to test for that we have to have
reaches to one location uh but two
objects that can appear at that location
and then we need a third novel object
which is only going to appear at test uh
and at test you contrast to reach to
a familiar object a re previously
reached for object at a new location
with a
new object at the old location and now
we see an effect at least as large of
learning to expect a reach to a location
as learning to expect a reach to an
object okay so i conclude from this that
infants can quickly learn at three
months
person's goal is either to get to a
particular object or to get to a
particular point in space
and what they learn depends on the
nature of the evidence that they're
getting
but before they learn that
they represent other people's actions as
goal directed they know this action has
a goal they just don't know which of two
goals it is and they need to get
information
about that
but there are limits to
interesting limits to
infants knowledge and i want to talk
about one using experiments on 15 month
old infants that gets to
issues about experience and
mental states uh that uh i know from
conversations today and yesterday that
many of you are interested in and which
and also i'm puzzling over these
experimental results now
okay these are studies with 15 month old
infants
and the first of them they both ask what
do infants understand about
other people's mental states when those
people are viewing the same array that
you're viewing but from a different
perspective so here's a situation where
infants were first shown you don't see
this here but they were first shown that
there are two photographs of faces
by the way all of these studies
including the ones i just told you about
were conducted over zoom during the
pandemic this is all new work
and most of them are not published yet
i'd love um you know people's reactions
to them but initially they see just the
two photographs so they're in view for
the this person this actor and also in
the infant's view of course
and then the occluders come down and the
occluders are placed so that one of the
objects is hidden from the baby's view
but visible to the actor and the other
is the reverse
and the actor now points to either
consistently
to the object that he can see or to the
screen covering the object he can't see
which of those two he points to is
counterbalanced across infants but
infants consistently see him doing one
or the other of those actions and the
question is how do they represent that
action do they represent it that he's
pointing to the screen that i'm looking
at or do they represent it as he's
pointing to the picture that he's
looking at okay um and to get at those
two uh distinctions we after that
familiarization the person moves to the
other side of the room so his
perspective and the infant's perspective
coincide and now depending on which
perspective they attributed to him they
would see one or the other of these
events as novel
and in that situation
this is the event that corresponds to
what they saw before they see this one
is more novel and look at it longer
providing evidence that
they do take account
of the visual access of the other person
to the object we showed this in this
study at 15 months it had previously
been shown
by luo and johnson at much younger ages
at three months of age using a simpler
situation but logically testing for the
same uh ability so that's something this
is a case where they seem to succeed in
distinguishing their own mental state
from that of another person contrast
that with this situation
we've got the same guy
we've got the same pictures but now
instead of a picture being either
visible or hidden
a picture is either upright or upside
down
and one of the two pictures is upright
and the other picture is upside down
to the actor and the actor's action is
to take the picture that's upside down
to him and turn it so that it's right
side up to him okay
and the question to the baby is what's
this person doing uh is he taking a
picture that he sees as upside down and
making it right side up as i just
described or is he taking a picture
that's right side up namely what the
baby sees and turning it so that it's
upside down and in this situation they
said
they do the egocentric thing and
represent you know the evidence is that
they they generalize to this display and
look longer at this one as if they
represented him as taking an upright
picture and turning it upside down what
what they saw from their perspective not
the um agents perspective so
as old as 15 months infants don't seem
to infer
that agents um
actions reflect their experiences of the
objects that they're acting on they they
depend on the visibility of the objects
that they're acting on but not on the
ways in which they themselves are
construing that object as right side up
or upside down i'm not going to show you
any more data but we've done this
experiment multiple times
using different variations on this
method and that's consistently been
the finding that we get we don't yet
know why this is we don't know whether
this is a there's one thing that's
different about this case from the gold
case the the location versus object case
i described before which is it's it's
not the case it doesn't it seems like
it's not the case that they understand
this guy's got experiences and that
experiences can differ but they don't
know what his specific experiences are
if that's all that was going on then
they should be equal between these two
events as they were between the place
and the location and that's not what we
see here but we don't know what is going
on
one possibility is that kids are just
locked into their own
view of the world i think we have
evidence against that but but
um
i won't talk about it now since uh
you're looking at your watch which tells
me oh no that's terrible and i haven't
gotten the core social cognition yet
okay i have to go faster um all right uh
never mind the uh
there's at least two possibilities left
once we rule that first one out one is
that they they don't have a sense of
other people's experiences at all only
of their own i think that's not going to
turn out to be true but it's possible
given these data
the other possibility is that they
understand that experiences can be
variable but they do not yet have the
means for determining how they're going
to vary for other people relative to how
they will vary for themselves and in the
absence of that information they fall
back on irregularity that's actually
useful in many circumstances which is
that very often
different parties observing the same
event will have the same experience
we're in a sad movie together and i'll
feel sad and you'll feel sad as well and
and infants may be reverting to
relying on that as a strategy while
waiting as maybe the pre-reaching
infants were waiting for more
information to disambiguate what the uh
experiences should be uh but that's as
far as i can go with that now i want to
turn to the um
studies of social beings and i'll try to
get through this super quickly so we get
to uh how children learn um
uh okay three findings very quickly on
one slide suggesting that there's a
distinct system for representing social
beings infants are highly sensitive to
faces that are looking at them
when people
change their facial expressions and
their facial movements they tend to
imitate them when people are looking
straight ahead and then turn to the side
to look to an object they they uh will
shift their attention to the same side
that the other person has shifted their
gaze to
uh this these these abilities are all
shown by non-human primates as well as
uh by human infants uh suggesting that
this is an ancient system and i think
these these findings also suggest that
the system centers on interconnected
abstract concepts of social engagement
and uh experience shareable
experiences that occur in
states of engagement but core social
knowledge is limited
um infants
up until about 10 months 9 or 10 months
of age
like people who imitate their social
gestures and their emotional expressions
and they'll tend to smile at them but
they're completely unmoved by people who
imitate their actions on objects
they also infants also tend to
view imitate when other people imitate
them they view that that imitation as
social if it involves purposeless
actions like waving your hands or
jumping up and down but not if it
involves instrumental
actions on objects suggesting that
infants can represent a person either as
an agent or as a social being but not as
both at the same time they can't
represent one action as simultaneously
social and object directed and and that
may be why until about 10 months of age
infants don't seem to have any notions
of
instrument actions that are both social
and instrumental like gift giving or
competition over resources or
cooperation
or helping
so it's an ancient limited system i
think distinct from the agent system and
that raises the question does it support
infants learning and this is the last
experiment i will uh tell you about well
actually i guess i have a slide that
leads up to it
the uh
there have been lots of studies there
have been lots of studies that have
shown that when you present babies with
characters that they don't know so
they're just third-party observers to
social interactions among other
characters they expect characters who
imitate one another to affiliate with
each other they expect characters who
comfort younger
characters smaller characters making
crying baby noises if two
adult characters seem to comfort the
same baby they expect them to affiliate
with each other
but what wasn't revealed by any of these
studies is what is what's the function
of these abilities and might they guide
infants learning about their own social
world and that's the question that
ashley thomas uh who also gets all the
credit for the saliva sharing studies
that i won't talk about has been
exploring with rebecca saxon me
recently here are some studies over zoom
that she
has conducted now for these studies she
first works with parents and gets
parents to make movies of themselves
using their webcam in which they're
staring straight ahead and then making
nonsense noises and looking to one side
or looking to the other side and then
she takes these movies and digitally
manipulates them to add puppets to the
movies so that she can present infants
with a with a movie and on their laptop
screen at home in which their parent
turns to a puppet the puppet says
something to the parent and the parent
imitates the puppet by repeating what
they said
so the structure of the study is there's
two puppets parent imitates one puppet
does not imitate the other puppet
and then the parent goes away the two
puppets are left they move their mouths
in synchrony and the baby hears hi brian
how are you and the question is brian
being the name of the baby the question
is who does who does the baby think
knows their name is it the person that
their uh parent
imitated so the full design of the study
is every baby is run through this study
twice with two different adults and two
different sets of puppets one of the
adults is their parent the other adult
is another the parent of another baby in
the study
they get to see the name calling and
they also get to see control events
where puppets dance to music there was
never any differential looking at the um
during the control events so i won't
show you that i'll just show you they're
looking to the puppet who called their
name and what you see is that when that
puppet had been imitated by their own
parent they looked to that puppet when
they heard their name being called but
when they saw a puppet who had been
imitated by another parent uh they did
not so it looks like um they're um
they're they're making an inference
about who's connected to them from
information about who
is uh connected uh to their parent but
what the study didn't yet tell us is
what kind of inference are they making
is it about a trait or is it about a
relationship this person is part of my
uh social network so to get at that
ashley's done more studies i'll tell you
just one of them where again you have a
parent condition and a stranger
condition
but in addition to having uh conditions
in which they see puppets who uh
experiments in which they see puppets
who face them and call to and hear a
voice calling to them by name there's a
comparison condition in which they see
puppets who face away from them and hear
a voice calling the name of another baby
in the study right so if they just think
these puppets are more likely to be
friendly you should see the same effects
in the two conditions but if you think
it's really about them
you'll see different effects and what
she in fact gets looking both at first
looks and also total looks oh i'm going
to be shut up soon um
yeah okay um is that the only effect is
when they've seen their parent they
puppet imitated by their parent calling
to them not calling uh to uh anybody
else
so final uh study uh
is this only about the baby who's is the
baby only concerned who's connected to
me or is the baby also concerned who's
connected to the people that i care
about last study i'll tell you about i
promise
so to get at that
ashley did one further study where she
now begins with two puppets one of whom
calls the baby by name and the other
dances in an equally engaging fashion uh
babies are equally interested in these
two events but shows no sign of
individual recognition of the baby and
then they see events in which an adult
expresses distress
to the two puppets are present they turn
toward the adult and the question is who
does the baby think is going to uh
comfort this adult in distress and the
baby is run through um two experiments
one in which the adult is their own
parent and the other in which the adult
is the parent of another baby and as you
can see when it's their own parent they
expect the parent to be comforted by the
puppet who knew their name not by the
other puppets so it looks like they're
not only learning who's connected to me
but what are the contours of my social
world they're starting uh to learn that
in infancy so i think what we have here
are three distinct and limited but
unitarian abstract systems of core
knowledge a system uh folks focused on
objects that move on agents that act and
on social beings that engage with one
another and share experiences i think we
also see evidence that infants don't
readily combine these systems even
though two of the systems at least focus
on the very same individuals uh but when
an individual is acting on an object
that engages one system when they're
when they're engaging with another
individual it engages and not another
but children's
fast and flexible learning can't depend
on these systems alone
because they're all shared by other
animals
and other animals don't learn don't
undergo this explosive cultural learning
that you see in children after the first
year and because core knowledge is
limited in the ways that i've already
described
so that then raises the question how
what accounts for infants uniquely human
learning and clearly i don't have time
to address that question now
i have slides addressing it i did not uh
as this is not the first time this has
happened to me that i've confidently
thought i would be done in 45 minutes
and i wasn't
but let me just say
that uh i think we see hints of an
answer if we look at another
developmental change that occurs over
the
first year of life
and that and actually starts before
birth
and that is that over the course of the
first year
children learn a great deal about the
language of the people in their social
world they learn what it sounds they
learn about language at all levels
simultaneously they learn about its
phonology they learn about its prosody
but they also learn about learn the
meanings of words starting with
recognizing their own name at about four
months of age uh they learn the
grammatical distinction between function
words and content words and they know
that [ __ ] they come to discover that
content words refer to things in the
world whereas function words pick out
the relationships among refer to
relationships among those things um all
of this they learn before they start to
talk and also before they start to talk
by learning these things ab about the
language that people are speaking they
learn things about those people and they
learn things about the world that those
people are speaking about about the
people i think they learn that they are
social agents whose actions can be
simultaneously social and agentive and i
think they
learn this when they hear people saying
things like look at the cup look at the
at the
bottle uh look is inviting the child to
engage with them and share an experience
cup or bottle is inviting them to share
an experience of an object okay i think
this brings a new conception of people
and their mental states but it also
gives children an extremely useful tool
for learning about the world
because people
are agents and therefore speak
efficiently
and they are also social beings and they
therefore speak relevantly and
informatively and helpfully and whether
people are speaking to the infant or to
somebody else or to themselves
when they talk they make
they make distinctions in what they call
things that reflect the distinctions
that they think are worth conveying and
relevant in the situation in which they
are in so if in an experiment by shu and
carrie where a 10 month old baby would
normally not distinct not to be able to
tell you whether there's a cup you know
a shoe on one side and a duck on the
other side
of a screen when they hear somebody
calling to them and labeling those
objects with different words they'll
infer that there's two different objects
there even if they've never seen
anything persons just looked into a box
and said look a blicket look a toma
they'll infer that there are two objects
in that box because you wouldn't go to
the effort of using two words if you
were only describing one thing
twice
so language becomes an incredibly useful
source of information for children to
discover what the cultural distinctions
are in the world that they're living in
and i think this is a beginning hint to
how children come to learn to learn uh
so fast and flexibly about the
particular environments they're in even
though the core knowledge that they're
equipped with is utterly uninformative
about the differences between one
environment and another since it it only
centers on these abstract concepts that
apply in every environment in uh exactly
the same way and i think with this uh
learning system
we get engaged in a process that leads
to the situation we find ourselves in as
adults where the vast majority of the
things that we know we do not know from
our direct experience we know from other
people
uh either people we know directly or
people
who reach us through news services or
social media or other things i think
this is both our greatest
gift for learning and also
an extreme potential source of
vulnerability uh because we're going to
learn most readily from sources that we
trust and if we don't all trust the same
sources that can bring us lots of
problems and then my the parting hope of
this talk had i've been able to give the
the last third of it was
okay i'm done i'm done i think maybe if
we understand all this stuff better we
can start to deal with some of those
problems thank you
oh
yeah we're gonna we're gonna we have
time for one or two questions
hi um i have a question about running
running the studies with the babies over
zoom
i actually used to work in karen wynn's
lab before shut down so that's pretty
interesting to me um
but i remember learning in one of my
classes that
um some things can't be learned on a
screen like a baby can only learn to
differentiate the phonemes of a
non-native language like from a speaker
not from watching a
tv or watching a movie um or someone on
the screen so i'm wondering if there are
there other limitations that you've
encountered that cannot be learned
through the screen that's a great
question um the the the condition the
the the study that you're talking about
is actually really interesting um it's a
it's a language learning study uh and
kids are exposed to a chinese speaker
and they either have the chinese speaker
come into their house and
talk to them directly or they see a
video of the chinese speaker who's gone
into somebody else's house and talked to
the um
that people there and there's no
question that the non-interactive video
led to no learning what's just like
children don't learn language from the
radio
they don't learn language under that
situation what we do over zoom though is
interactive video so there's a real
experimenter there who talks uh to the
baby at the beginning of the study that
mom is involved in setting up the study
and mom is conversing with the
experimenter at that time the baby gets
to see all of that these babies also
were being tested during the pandemic
which means they're interacting with
grandparents over video and other uh
family relatives it was really the ideal
time to run a study and but but i have
to tell you i i was very pessimistic
when we started working with zoom the
reason we started working with zoom is
that there were
grad students in my lab who were highly
optimistic about it and they they they
uh talked me out of my pessimism and you
know and so we tried it out but i
thought there were 100 reasons why these
studies wouldn't work and you've
mentioned one of them another reason why
i thought they wouldn't work is that the
environments would be so variable and
full of distractions we're testing kids
in their kitchens there's dogs running
around the phone is ringing i mean you
know all kinds of distress and we're
measuring looking time i thought this
will never work it works so well the
babies are so much more relaxed in their
own kitchen than they ever were when
they came into my lab and we went into
the sound attenuated rooms and we turned
the lights down and they would look
around like what kind of weird
environment is this and the parents
would sometimes look a little ilities at
home everybody is relaxed the kids are
watching the videos it works super well
and we haven't yet found a situation
where we can run the tests at all
that hasn't worked as well on uh video
as it used to work uh in the lab
generally i for most of our studies we
never want to go back um however there
are things we can't do and one of them
actually was a study that was maybe
going on in karen's lab when uh uh you
were still there looking at whether
presenting kids with plants i really
wanted to do these studies and present
kids with plants and see whether they
would distinguish plants from art you
know inanimate are you living plants
from inanimate artifacts by their their
forms and functions and for that they
the outcome measure that karen used was
um
latency to touch an object would they be
more hesitant to touch a plant than to
touch an artifact and that i don't know
how to do over zoom so we haven't been
able to run everything um but i think
you're absolutely right that kids are
predisposed to learn from people uh that
they feel socially connected to it's
just that in the pandemic era you can
achieve that with interactive video
hi thanks for the um really wonderful
talk um
i just wanted to ask a question about um
the neonatal kind of imitation that was
uh featured
several times in your talk um there's
some like recent work that suggests that
there are alternatives to
um the imitation theory for the
um the neonatal work like one of them
being that like
um
for very young babies in neonates like
they tend to make um stereotypic
movements and when they see a human
they're excited and they're more likely
to make those gestures so
um you know those work they um they
haven't been reliably replicated and
like theoretically there has been some
lots of interesting um papers that
discuss these alternatives i mean i
don't think from the core knowledge
perspective like it doesn't make a
my perspective it doesn't make a huge
impact to the extent that you see this
in other primates as well um but i just
wonder if and of course segmentation
plays a huge role in development i just
think maybe a little bit later um yeah
um so you're are you talking mostly
about the current biology paper that
came out like yeah before you hate and
yeah yeah i don't read that i don't read
that as a non-replication of the um
imitation studies uh what the original
imitation studies had shown this by the
way is all work by
andy meltzoff who has a nice reply to
that current biology paper in
developmental science but
what the original imitation studies had
shown
is that not that infants
are motorically capable of precisely
imitating what someone else does not at
all but that if you give them enough
time
they will attempt to reproduce as best
they can the movements that they saw and
they will not only do that immediately
they'll do it after a delay of an hour
and they'll do it after a delay of a day
if they see that same person again now
what was done in the current biology
paper is they saw
the babies got to see a single person
they did one gesture
they gave the baby i think a minute to
respond maybe 30 seconds not very long
then they did a second gesture then they
did a third gesture then they did a
fourth different gestures each time
that had never been done in the original
imitation literature what they reported
is that babies imitated all the gestures
but they didn't imitate it in that first
30 second window it would take them
longer to produce the gestures over time
and what andy meltzoff has has argued is
it was because they used that method
that what they found at the end was yes
we see all these gestures but they're
not immediately following what they saw
before and andy agrees it doesn't occur
immediately after
but but
he argues that it does occur and the
paper uh where he argues this draws both
on the data from human infants and also
on data uh from studies that he wasn't
even involved in that were conducted
with monkeys and with chimpanzees that
showed the same effects this very uh
slow delayed partial reproduction by the
way what i think is interesting about
imitation
for years i was puzzled by imitation why
are babies doing this i think the reason
that they're doing it is it's the it's
the one reliable signal that they're
able to give to someone that they're
attending to that person
and they're motivated to engage with
them in the moment right they can't use
language to to say that they don't have
any specific cultural knowledge that
they can draw on to indicate just that
to somebody the one thing they can do
is
copy somebody's action and as something
that's very unlikely to happen simply
randomly by chance if you weren't uh
both attending to that person and
motivated to signal uh your state of
attention and engagement so that's
that's all i think that the um the
imitation is about uh it's been uh
eliciting controversies though for
40 years now uh since the original
reports in the uh in in the 70s and it's
clear that these are very subtle
phenomena that you that you see uh early
on
i wouldn't put a lot of stock on this
being full-blown imitation but i do
think it's saying something about a
baby's effort to signal to somebody that
they're engaged with them maybe in the
same way that these kind of movements
that an ena will engage in might be an
effort to signal i'd really like to be
able to reach for that thing even though
i can't do that right now
one last question
i'm interested to hear you say a little
bit more about
um
the special role that language plays in
sort of human cognition so we've talked
about all these different core systems
and they're sort of separate and we
can't use them at the same time but then
you were saying something really
interesting right at the end and i want
to give you a chance to say a little bit
more about this
um
about how
language is an interesting sort of
integration of some of these systems and
it seems like really plausible for me
when it comes to like
um maybe
object and
social stuff but i was wondering if yeah
if other
systems get integrated by this sort of
language process as well or
yeah that's actually what my whole
second book is is going to be about
because i think there's many many cases
not only um
uh
infants developing understanding of
other people or infants developing
ability to categorize objects as
instances of kinds which are the two
things that i think we see infants using
language for at the end of the first
year but also other abilities like
their discovery of the natural numbers
their discovery of other symbol systems
and developing abilities to communicate
with other people by means of spatial
symbols for example
of the sort that will eventually figure
in maps and reading and and pictures and
uh things like that um so yeah i think
there's there you know there are many
domains
i as far as i can see actually in every
domain where you see children's
knowledge taking off before they get to
school without anybody instructing them
in anything it looks to me like it's
associated with changes in their
language theory of mind is another great
example of that so then your question
what is it about language now
initially i thought that the primary uh
feature of language that made it such a
good tool for learning about the world
was that it was a compositional system
so where where um once you know the
meanings of words and you know the
grammatical structure of a sentence you
get the meaning of the sentence for free
uh so if a child knows that a word you
know when they hear an expression uh
like um
look laurie a duck okay uh if they know
the meaning of the word look if if look
it indicates for them and an invitation
to engage and share an experience
uh uh and and it's directed at
at a specific person so they know it's
for them uh and uh it's followed by a
duck
uh a duh and they know that a doc refers
to a kind of a an object you know at
least this individual object if not yet
a kind of object that then if they hear
this as a sentence expressing a specific
thought
the thought has both social content and
its object directed okay so it's both it
and i i think that suggests that it's
reflecting a mental state that's both
phenomenal and intentional uh and
they're getting that from the
combinatorial uh properties of language
but i now think actually
uh there's another related aspect of
language that might be just as important
which is that uh babies seem to already
know uh early on that they can engage
with other people to share experiences
experiences of emotion of action with
imitation and
things like that
but
i think what happens at the
end of the first year
is that they come to discover
that they can share experiences that cut
up the world more finely than just
experiences of an object they can share
experiences of an object under a
particular description so for example
when a person says to a kid look at that
dog over there that's our neighbor's dog
or look at that dog that's fido okay
they're using two different words now if
babies expect people to be efficient
they don't expect them to use two
different words to convey the same
experience but they're talking about the
same object so they must be using two
different words to convey two different
experiences of that object that can be
shared with the child and i think this
may be really really important for
learning think about how you could teach
somebody that the stars up in the sky
are enormous suns you know as large or
larger than our sun and very very far
away you could point at a star all day
long and you're not going to be able to
convey that
language is an ideal medium for
conveying those kinds of experiences and
i think that's the kind of learning that
kids get into at the end of the first
year of life and throughout the
preschool years and and we we continue
to do it throughout our lives but it's
really central i think to kids learning
over the course of the preschool years
uh and it's just based on fundamental
assumptions that people are
social and therefore they will share
their experiences with kids but they
also are agents who act on objects and
so they can share experiences of objects
and they will act efficiently so when
you see when you see what they choose to
say and what they choose not to say
you can infer from that what they see as
relevantly alike in the world and what
they see is different what distinctions
they think need to be made in the
situation they're in to be sharing um
experiences within that situation does
that make any sense okay those are kind
of the general ideas about language
awesome so students we're going to go
upstairs
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you